anunció que busca cambiar la opinión de
muchos escépticos la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de eeuu aprueba
totalmente la vacuna de fisher y bryant
contra el coi 19
si bien esta y otras vacunas han
cumplido con los rigurosos estándares
científicos de la sda para la
autorización del uso de emergencia como
la primera vacuna kobe 19 aprobada por
la rda el público puede estar seguro de
que esta vacuna cumple con los
estándares máximos de la fd en cuanto a
seguridad eficacia y calidad de
fabricación que requerimos para un
producto aprobado
en diciembre el regulador de
medicamentos estadounidense permitió su
uso de emergencia para inocular a
personas de 16 años en adelante más
tarde en mayo la autorizó para menores a
partir de los 12 años más de 204
millones de personas han recibido esta
vacuna en eeuu sin embargo alrededor de
85 millones de estadounidenses que son
elegibles para vacunarse son escépticos
y no lo han hecho sólo amistades
rawlings blake
permítanme decir esto en voz alta y
clara si usted es uno de los millones de
estadounidenses que dijeron que no
recibirían la inyección hasta que no
cuenten con la aprobación total y final
de la fd ahora esto acaba de suceder
llegó el momento que ha estado esperando
es hora de vacunarse por ser tan firme
que racing un poco después del anuncio
de la rda el pentágono exigirá que 13
millones de militares estén obligados a
vacunarse el alcalde de nueva york
también dijo que emitirá una orden para
exigir que los 148.000 maestros y
personal de escuelas públicas de la
ciudad reciban al menos una dosis de la
vacuna antes del 27 de septiembre
después del inicio de clases lo mismo
sucederá con el personal escolar en
chicago los ángeles y washington las
autoridades esperan que la aprobación
impulso en un aumento en la tasa de
inmunización en todo el país en medio
del aumento en los contagios debido a la
variante delta